on commence avec la plus belle c'était
pas compliqué ça fait deux semaines de
suite qu'elle va gratuitement et ça
plaît beaucoup beaucoup à cyril hanouna
rider il m'a dit jamais deux sans trois
rachat grâce à de cyril merci pour ta
beauté est à gratuité d'accord quand
j'aime je ne compte pas ah ben ça alors
ça fallait pas le dire vous connaissez
la mère noël et ben nous on a en
exclusivité l'arrière arrière vous
prouver qu'elle n'est pas en taille et
qu'elle parle encore je la touche j'ai
la torre l'arrivée à luz et non c'est
pas mal ça va du coup tu sais quoi
isabelle morini-bosc lève alors prêtre
du jeune isabelle jeune je ne suis pas
on l'appelle ces mois là
ces deux mois dans vous allez vous
[ __ ] on l'appelle le lutin de la bande
parce qu'il adore agitée ces gros gros
lot le produit
et ne permettent pas s'ils jouent je
vois pas qui vous permet sûr que mes
séméga gros lots sont plus gros que les
veaux tout ça je ne sais pas d'où venait
ce bruit mais ma les messieurs et lucho
familiale et multifamiliales me plaît
beaucoup
elle a déjà s'est tenue pour la soirée
de noël et on vous l'a révèle en exclure
regardez la photo
voilà et ça c'est sans maquillage et
vous verrez peut-être séjour sur les
coulisses de tp avant le maquillage
[Musique]
vraiment aux maquilleuses c'est un
travail de malade mental on ne dira
jamais assez
c'est alors rangé un jour basware je ne
vous connais pas je suis chef chez
lidocaïne dit il est fan de mariah carey
mais tout ce qu'il a pris d'elle cette
année c'est son physique lui quand je
verrai pas là je vais vous dire là
cela je vais vous dire c'est internet
des auteurs qui sont avec nous sont là
on l'est on les vire pour 2009 a
vraiment ce qu'ils ont dit oui le pris
un peu de poids et au delà c'est
magnifique c'est fait bodine catherine
elle est comme ça ça va ça va m'arriver
catherine cette année-là demandé au père
noël de rajeunir de dix ans il a exaucé
son voeu
elle aura 50 ans cette année des
démissions pour ça je suis de plus en
plus près de la porte de sortie n'est
pas du tout sûr mais aussi avec reed
evans mais il est beau on l'appelle le
brad pitt jeune matthieu delormeau avec
nous